das wasser vor floridas küsten sieht aus
wie vom blut getränkt die sogenannte
rote flut entsteht durch die
explosionsartige ausbreitung von
einzellern konkret handelt es sich um
eine intensive algenblüte mit
dramatischen folgen mehr als 100 tonnen
toter lebewesen wurden allein schon im
august an die strände gespült die
unzähligen opfer delfine fische
meeresschildkröten seekühe und viele
weitere große und kleine meeresbewohner
aber auch menschen sind bedroht wie
dramatisch die lage vor ort wirklich ist
wie die helfer mit der situation umgehen
und warum wir menschen schuld an der
katastrophe haben das alles jetzt bei
pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen und am ende kündige ich noch
eine ziemlich gute geile aktion an hoffe
ich doch zumindest das ganze macht einen
körperlich und seelisch fertig sagt eine
der helferinnen gretchen of well vor ort
sie arbeitet für das wissenschaftliche
meeres institut mode marine laboratory
in florida und sammelt mittlerweile
schon seit wochen tag für tag die toten
und halb toten tiere an den stränden
floridas ein hier stinkt es bestialisch
kein wunder in dieser todeszone das was
hier passiert ist nicht weniger als ein
wirklich dramatisches massensterben
fischkadaver über fischkadaver und stadt
blauem wasser vor malerischen stränden
hat sich das meer hier in eine grün
rötliche brühe verwandelt vor einiger
zeit waren die strände hier noch
malerisch und gehörten mit dem zu bild
zu den beliebtesten urlaubsregionen der
welt davon ist ja jetzt überhaupt nichts
mehr zu spüren verendet sind die tiere
alle durch die sogenannte rote thiede
oder auch rote flut genannt ausgelöst
durch eine sehr intensive algenblüte die
den sauerstoffgehalt im wasser senkt und
zudem auch noch giftstoffe produziert
unter den opfern sind auch schon mehr
als zwölf delfine so viele tote tiere
werden sonst in einem ganzen jahr
an den stränden in der region
aufgefunden die anfänge der roten flut
fanden schon im vergangenen oktober
statt jetzt hat sich die algenblüte
massiv ausgeweitet forschungsteams haben
das massensterben vor allem an der
westküste von florida registriert die
rote flut erstreckt sich hier mehr als
320 kilometer an der küste entlang von
kampa bis naples konkret werden die
einzeller namens carina briefes und die
augen tierchen lena
sangui näher für das massensterben
verantwortlich gemacht die einzeller
schwimmen gegen die schwerkraft zum
licht hin und können eine
geschwindigkeit von einem meter pro
stunde erreichen sie greifen extrem in
das ökosystem ein verfärben das wasser
rot und produzieren eine reihe von
giften
diese sogenannten breve toxine sind
giftige stoffwechselprodukte der alpen
das problem sie können sich innerhalb
der nahrungskette anreichern das heißt
sie werden immer mehr von toxinen
belasteten fischen muscheln und krebsen
kann das gift dann auch zum menschen
gelangen bei uns wird solch eine
vergiftung neurotoxin schellfischposten
nsb bezeichnet die patienten und
patientinnen leiden an husten
kopfschmerzen und tränenden augen die
vergiftung gilt zudem als auslöser für
asthma medien in der region berichten
bereits von vorfällen und es gibt
warnhinweise den kontakt mit den algen
und dem wasser unbedingt zu vermeiden
die meeresbewohner dagegen sind dem gift
schutzlos ausgeliefert das fatale die
tiere nehmen das gift nicht nur über die
nahrung sondern auch über die haut auf
es führt zu koordinationsproblemen
orientierungslosigkeit und krämpfen und
am schluss spätestens durch den
sauerstoffmangel zum tod zu der
giftwirkung führt die dichte an
phytoplankton an der wasseroberfläche zu
dem auch zu eben dem verminderten
sauerstoffgehalt und dadurch wird das
massensterben weiter begünstigt die
tiere ersticken qualvoll
das phänomen der roten flut ist übrigens
nicht neu im gegenteil es handelt sich
um ein uraltes naturphänomen die
einzelner kommen das ganze jahr über in
den gewässern vor und die algen blühen
regelmäßig es gibt theorien nach denen
das rote meer nach genau diesem phänomen
benannt ist die us-regierung hat die
erste red an floridas küsten im jahr
1840 offiziell dokumentiert doch die
ausmaße der gefährlichen algenblüte
werden immer extremer
das hauptproblem sind zu viele
nährstoffe die vor allem durch die
menschen ins wasser gelangen diese
lassen die algen schnell wachsen und
große bestände aufbauen experten und
expertinnen zufolge liegt der ursprung
des übels etwas weiter nordwestlich der
aktuell betroffenen regionen durch die
überdüngung des mississippi gelangen zu
viele nährstoffe in den golf von mexiko
doch man muss auch gar nicht so weit
gucken um ähnliche prozesse zu finden
auch in europäischen gewässern wie
beispielsweise in großen teilen der
ostsee fehlt in den tieferen
wasserschichten der sauerstoff
der gouverneur von florida hat
jedenfalls den notstand für sieben
counties ausgerufen und mehr als 1,5
millionen us-dollar für ein
hilfsprogramm versprochen für die
bewohner und bewohnerinnen bleibt nicht
mehr als aufzuräumen und zu hoffen dass
die rote flut bald beendet ist
langfristig gesehen sind politik und
landwirtschaft gefragt der einsatz von
dünger muss stark reduziert werden um
neue todes bringen die fluten in der
zukunft zu verhindern
und jetzt in eigener sache wir machen
klicks um werbefrei keine priols mehr
und ihr könnt das na ja fast unmögliche
möglich machen denn uns geht es nicht
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung von jeweils einem video im
monat ab bis es vor keinem video mehr
werbung gibt wenn das nicht sensationell
es wäre es also mitglied hier unter dem
video oder auf dem kanal und bekommt
noch exklusive extra videos exklusive
live streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien einfach hier eben unter dem
video auf mitglied werden klicken
tausend dank an diejenigen die schon
dabei sind wenn er immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt
dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die bei einigen etwas
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video mehr einfach
hier draufklicken und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
riesenproblem plastikmüll auch im meer
was ganz schlimmes was hilft bis dann
bleibt dran